En primer lugar me gustaría llevarlos
a lo que se piensa que sería el abismo natural más profundo del mundo.
Y digo se piensa porque este proceso aún continua.
En este momento se están planeando grandes expediciones para el próximo año
y voy a hablar un poco sobre eso.
Una de las cosas que ha cambiado
en los últimos 150 años, desde que Julio Verne
tuvo grandiosas nociones de ciencia ficción sobre cómo era el mundo subterráneo,
es que la tecnología nos ha permitido ir a estos lugares que anteriormente
eran completamente desconocidos y sobre los que sólo se podía especular.
Ahora podemos descender miles de metros dentro de la tierra con relativa impunidad.
En el camino hemos descubierto abismos fantásticos y cámaras tan grandes
que se puede ver por cientos de metros
sin interrupción en la línea de visión.
Cuando vas a un lugar así normalmente estás en terreno
por un período de dos a cuatro meses,
con un equipo que puede ser desde como de 20 o 30 hasta como de 150.
Y mucha gente me pregunta, ustedes saben,
¿qué tipo de gente consigues para un proyecto así?
Y mientras que nuestro proceso de selección
no es tan riguroso como en la NASA, es igual de completo.
Buscamos competencia, disciplina, resistencia y fuerza.
En caso de que se lo pregunten, esta es nuestra prueba de fuerza.
(Risas)
Pero también valoramos la camaradería
y la habilidad para resolver conflictos interpersonales diplomáticamente
estando bajo gran presión en lugares remotos.
Ya hemos sobrepasado por mucho los límites de la resistencia humana.
Viéndola desde la entrada, no se parece en lo absoluto a una caverna comercial.
Están viendo el Campo Dos en un lugar llamado J2, no K2 sino J2.
Ahí ya estamos a más o menos dos días de la entrada.
Y es como un viaje de montañismo de gran altura en reversa,
excepto que ahora estás haciendo bajar cuerdas por estas cosas.
La idea es tratar de proveer cierta cantidad de comodidad física
mientras estás ahí abajo, en condiciones húmedas y frías en lugares totalmente oscuros.
Por cierto, debo mencionar que todo lo que ven aquí
está iluminado artificialmente con gran esfuerzo.
De otra manera estaría completamente oscuro en estos lugares.
Entra más desciendes, más entras en conflicto con el agua.
Básicamente es como un árbol que recolecta agua caída.
Y eventualmente llegas a lugares donde es formidable y peligroso
y desafortunadamente las fotos no le hacen justicia.
Así que tengo aquí un breve video que fue tomado a finales de los 80s.
Desciendan hacia dentro de la Meseta de Huatla en México.
(Video)
Debo decirles que las técnicas mostradas aquí
son obsoletas y peligrosas.
No haríamos esto hoy en día a menos que fuera para una película.
(Risas)
Y siguiendo en la misma línea debo decirles
que con la avalancha de películas de Hollywood que salieron el año pasado,
aún no hemos visto monstruos bajo tierra...
al menos no del tipo que te comen.
Si existe un monstruo bajo tierra
es la aplastante lejanía psicológica
que comienza a impactar a cada miembro del equipo
cuando ya te adentras tres días desde la entrada más cercana.
El próximo año estaré dirigiendo a un equipo internacional al J2.
Estaremos intentando llegar a menos 2.600 metros,
un poco más de 8.600 pies de profundidad,
a 30 kilómetros de la entrada.
Los equipos de avanzada estarán bajo tierra cerca de 30 días seguidos.
No creo que haya habido una misión como esta en mucho tiempo.
Eventualmente si sigues descendiendo por estas cosas,
la probabilidad dice que te encontrarás lugares como este.
Es un lugar donde hay un pliegue en el estrato geológico
que recolecta agua y que se llena hasta el techo.
Y cuando solías encontrar estas cosas
le ponías una etiqueta al mapa que decía "sifón terminal".
Ahora, recuerdo ese término muy bien por dos razones.
Número uno, es el nombre de mi banda de rock y dos,
es porque enfrentarme a estas cosas
me forzó a convertirme en inventor.
Y desde entonces hemos desarrollado
muchas generaciones de aparatos para explorar lugares como este.
Este es un equipo de apoyo vital de ciclo cerrado
y puedes usarlo ahora para ir horizontalmente por muchos kilómetros
bajo el agua y para bajar directamente a profundidades de 200 metros.
Cuando haces este tipo de cosas es como realizar una AEV,
como hacer una Actividad Extra-Vehicular en el espacio
pero a mucha mayor distancia y con mucho mayor peligro físico.
Así que te hace pensar en cómo diseñar tu equipo
para usarlo a gran distancia de un refugio seguro.
Aquí hay un clip de una película de National Geographic
que salió en 1999.
(Narrador de Video) "La exploración es el proceso físico
de poner tu pie en lugares donde los humanos nunca han pisado antes.
Este es el último territorio totalmente desconocido que queda en el planeta.
Experimentarlo es un privilegio."
Eso fue filmado en Wakulla Springs, Florida.
Un par de cosas que recalcar sobre esa película: cada pieza de equipo
que vieron ahí no existía antes de 1999.
Fue desarrollado en un período de dos años y usado en proyectos de exploración reales.
Este aparato que ven aquí se llama mapeador digital de paredes
y produjo el primer mapa tridimensional que alguien haya hecho
de una cueva y sucedió bajo el agua en Wakulla Springs.
Este dispositivo fue el que accidentalmente abrió la puerta
a otro mundo inexplorado.
Esta es Europa.
Carolyn Porco mencionó otra llamada Encélado el otro día.
Este es uno de los lugares donde los científicos planetarios
creen que existe una alta probabilidad de que por primera vez
se detecte vida fuera de la Tierra, en el océano que existe ahí debajo.
Para aquellos que nunca han visto esta historia
Jim Cameron produjo una fantástica película en IMAX
hace unos años llamada "Criaturas del Abismo"
Aquí hay un breve clip:
(Narrador de Video) "Una misión para explorar bajo el hielo de Europa
será el desafío robótico definitivo.
Europa está tan lejos que incluso a la velocidad de la luz
enviar una orden tomaría más de una hora en llegar al vehículo.
Debe ser lo suficientemente inteligente para evitar amenazas en el terreno
y encontrar un buen lugar de aterrizaje en el hielo.
Ahora debemos atravesar el hielo.
Se necesita una sonda que lo derrita.
Básicamente es un torpedo calentado a reacción nuclear.
El hielo puede medir desde 5 a 26 kilómetros de profundidad.
Semana tras semana, la sonda se hundirá bajo su propio peso
a través del hielo antiguo, hasta que finalmente...
Ahora, ¿qué harás cuando llegues a la superficie de ese océano?
Necesitas un VSA, un Vehículo Submarino Autónomo.
Necesita ser un chico muy inteligente, capaz de navegar
y tomar decisiones propias en un océano alienígena."
Lo que Jim no sabía cuando lanzó la película
es que seis meses antes la NASA financió un equipo que yo había reunido
para desarrollar un prototipo del VSA para Europa.
Es decir, pasé por tres años de reuniones de ingeniería, diseño
e integración de sistemas e introduje DEPTHX,
Explorador Termal de Profundidades Freáticas.
Y como dice la película este es un chico muy inteligente.
Tiene 96 sensores, 36 computadoras de a bordo,
100 mil líneas de código de conducta autónoma,
llevando más de 10 kilos de TNT abordo como equivalente eléctrico.
Este es el sitio objetivo,
la fuente hidrotermal más profunda del mundo en el Cenote Zacatón al norte de México.
Ha sido explorado hasta una profundidad de 292 metros
pero nadie sabe que hay más allá.
Esta es parte de la misión de DEPTHX.
Hay dos objetivos principales que llevaremos a cabo aquí.
Uno es: ¿cómo haces ciencia autónomamente bajo tierra?
¿Cómo tomas un robot y lo conviertes en un microbiólogo de campo?
Hay más etapas involucradas aquí
que el tiempo que tengo para contarles, pero básicamente avanzamos
a través del espacio, lo poblamos con variables medio ambientales
como sulfuro, halogenuro, cosas como esas.
Calculamos los gradientes de las superficies y llevamos al robot hacia una pared
donde haya gran probabilidad de vida.
Nos movemos por la pared, en lo que se llaman operaciones de proximidad,
buscando cambios en el color.
Si vemos algo que se vea interesante lo ponemos bajo el microscopio.
Si pasa la prueba microscópica tomamos una muestra.
Podemos tomar una muestra líquida
o podemos tomar un núcleo sólido de la pared.
Sin manos al volante.
Todo es comportamiento autónomo
que está siendo conducido por el robot.
El truco realmente impresionante de este vehículo
es un sistema de navegación disruptivo que hemos desarrollado,
conocido como 3D SLAM, por Localización Y Mapeo Simultáneo.
DEPTHX es un ojo que todo lo ve.
Sus haces sensores ven hacia adelante y atrás al mismo tiempo
permitiéndole realizar nuevas exploraciones
mientras aún está fijando una imagen con sensores geométricos
de lo que ya ha pasado.
Lo que les voy a mostrar a continuación
es la primera exploración robótica subterránea totalmente autónoma
que se haya hecho jamás.
En mayo de este año iremos mil metros para abajo en Zacatón
y, si tenemos mucha suerte, DEPTHX traerá la primera
división de bacteria descubierta robóticamente.
El siguiente paso después de eso será probarlo en la Antártica y después,
si el financiamiento continúa y la NASA sigue con la intención de ir,
potencialmente podríamos despegar en 2016 y para el 2019
podríamos tener la primera evidencia de vida fuera del planeta.
¿Entonces qué pasa con la exploración tripulada al espacio?
El gobierno anunció recientemente sus planes para regresar a la luna en 2024.
La conclusión exitosa de esa misión resultará
en visitas no frecuentes a la luna por una cantidad pequeña
de científicos y pilotos del gobierno.
No nos llevará más allá de lo que estuvimos hace 50 años
en la expansión general de la humanidad al espacio.
Algo fundamental debe cambiar
si queremos ver acceso general al espacio en nuestras vidas.
Lo que les voy a mostrar a continuación son un par de ideas controvertidas.
Y espero que me aguanten y tengan algo de fe
en que hay algo de credibilidad en lo que vamos a hablar aquí.
Requieres tres fundamentos para trabajar privadamente en el espacio.
Uno de ellos es que necesitas
de transporte tierra-a-espacio económico.
Los Burt Rutans y Richard Bransons de este mundo
tienen esto como objetivo y brindo por ellos.
Vamos, vamos, vamos.
La siguiente cosa que necesitamos son lugares para permanecer en órbita.
Hoteles orbitales para empezar pero después talleres para el resto de nosotros.
La última pieza faltante, el verdadero rompedor de paradigmas, es este:
una estación de combustible en órbita.
No se va a ver así.
Si existiera, cambiaría todo el diseño de naves espaciales y planificación de misiones espaciales futuras.
Ahora, para darles oportunidad de entender
por qué esta afirmación es tan poderosa,
debo explicarles lo básico de Espacio 101.
Y lo primero es que todo lo que haces en el espacio lo pagas por kilogramo.
¿Alguien bebió uno de estos aquí esta semana?
Pagarían 10 mil dólares por esto en órbita.
Es más de lo que pagarían por TED
si Google abandonara su patrocinio.
(Risas)
Lo segundo es que más del 90% del peso de un vehículo es combustible.
Entonces, cada vez que quieras hacer algo en el espacio,
literalmente estás quemando enormes sumas de dinero
cada vez que pisas el acelerador.
Ni siquiera los chicos de Tesla pueden contra esa física.
Así que, ¿qué tal si pudieras conseguir gas a un décimo del precio?
Hay un lugar donde puedes.
De hecho puede obtenerlo mejor, a 14 veces menos,
si es que puedes encontrar combustible en la luna.
Hay una misión poco conocida que fue lanzada
por el Pentágono hace 13 años llamada "Clementine".
Y lo más increíble que se obtuvo de esa misión
fue una fuerte firma de hidrógeno en el cráter Shackleton
en el polo sur de la luna.
La señal era tan fuerte
que sólo pudo haber sido producida por 10 billones de toneladas de agua
enterradas en el sedimento, recolectadas por millones de millones de años
por el impacto de asteroides y material de cometas.
Si vamos a obtener eso y hacer posible esa estación de combustible
debemos encontrar formas de mover grandes volúmenes de carga por el espacio.
Hoy día no podemos hacerlo.
La forma en que normalmente se construye un sistema hoy en día
es construyendo una pila de tubos que se lanzan desde la tierra
y resisten todo tipo de fuerzas aerodinámicas.
Tenemos que superar eso.
Podemos hacerlo porque en el espacio no hay aerodinámica.
Podemos usar sistemas inflables para casi todo.
Esta es una idea que, nuevamente, vino de Livermore en 1989
con el grupo del Dr. Lowell Wood.
Y ahora podemos extender eso a casi todo.
Bob Bigelow actualmente tiene un artículo de prueba en órbita.
Podemos ir mucho más lejos.
Podemos construir remolcadores espaciales, plataformas para contener criogénicos y agua.
Hay otra cosa.
Cuando regresas de la luna
tienes que lidiar con mecánicas orbitales.
Se dice que te mueves 3 mil metros por segundo más rápido
de lo que en realidad quieres ir regresando a tu estación de combustible.
Tienes dos opciones.
Puedes quemar combustible para llegar ahí o puedes hacer algo increíble.
Puedes zambullirte en la estratósfera
y rebotando de forma precisa disipar esa velocidad y salir devuelta a la estación espacial.
Nunca se ha hecho.
Es riesgoso y será un viaje infernalmente bueno,
mejor que Disney.
El enfoque tradicional a la exploración espacial
ha sido que cargues con todo el combustible que requieras
para traer a todos de vuelta en caso de emergencia.
Si tratas de enviar una tripulación a la luna
haciendo eso, sólo en combustible vas a quemar mil millones de dólares.
Pero si mandas primero a un equipo de mineros
sin el combustible de regreso...
(Risas)
¿Alguno de ustedes ha escuchado la historia de Cortez?
Esto no es así. Soy mucho más como Scotty.
Me gustan estos equipos, saben, y en realidad los valoro
así que no vamos a quemarlos.
Pero si fueras realmente atrevido podrías llegar allí, fabricar el combustible,
y sería la demostración más dramática
de que puedes hacer algo que valga la pena fuera del planeta
que nunca se haya hecho antes.
Hay un mito que dice que no puedes hacer nada en el espacio
por menos de un billón de dólares y 20 años.
Eso no es verdad.
En siete años podríamos llevar
una misión industrial a Shackleton y demostrar
que puedes proveer una realidad comercial en órbita baja.
Estamos viviendo en uno de las épocas más excitantes de la historia.
Donde la confluencia mágica de la riqueza privada
y la imaginación nos llevan a demandar acceso al espacio.
Las estaciones orbitales de combustible que describí
podrían crear una industria completamente nueva y proveer la llave final
para abrir el espacio a la exploración general.
Para romper el paradigma, se requiere de una aproximación radicalmente distinta.
Podemos hacerlo de salto comenzando con
una expedición industrial de Lewis y Clark al cráter Shackleton,
para minar los recursos de la luna y demostrar
que estos pueden formar la base de un atractivo negocio en órbita.
Pareciera que las discusiones sobre el espacio siempre terminan colgadas
en ambigüedades de propósito y sincronización.
Me gustaría terminar aquí poniendo una estaca en la arena en TED.
Declaro que pretendo liderar esa expedición.
(Aplausos)
Puede hacerse en siete años con el respaldo adecuado.
Los que se unan a mí para hacerlo realidad serán parte de la historia
y se unirán a otros individuos osados del pasado
quienes, de estar hoy aquí, hubieran aprobado sinceramente.
Hubo un tiempo en el cual la gente hacía cosas atrevidas para abrir las fronteras.
Nos hemos olvidado grupalmente de esa lección.
Ahora estamos en una época en la que se requiere audacia para avanzar.
Cien años después que Sir Ernest Shackleton escribiera estas palabras,
declaro que pretendo plantar una bandera industrial en la luna
y completar la pieza final
que abrirá la frontera espacial, en nuestro tiempo, para todos nosotros.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)